the introduction
um
so yeah I'm going to talk about anything
Dynamic graph algorithms so I one slide
talk about Dynamic graph algorithms
introduce number I think um
familiar to
fullness everyone you're in room so I
just want to make sure that you're on
the same page here
um so um I assume that we have um then I
make a graphite algorithm which is
actually a data structure so it gets to
see the graph first at some point which
we call the initialization phase and
then it can produce an output so compute
something on it and then later on it
only gets to see updates of the graph
um and then it um we assume that it
produces only
um it tells us only what to what how the
output changes um in response to those
updates
um and we also assume that the output is
generated in response to a query so the
query might be explicit like um
tell me something about the graph in its
current state or implicit so whenever I
do an update um I expect my data
structure to just output the solution or
the difference into the previous
solution
so um what I mean by an update is
insertion deletion of a single edge or
the change of its weight by some Delta
unequal to zero so either weight
increases or decreases
um a bat is just a group of multiple
updates
um in some order can be um the updates
can be mixed as well
and I will assume that a batch always
contains at most One update to every
Edge so it cannot happen that within a
batch and it just modified twice or
something like that
um and the updates and batches arrive
one at a time and they are unknown to
the algorithm beforehand so the
algorithm does not know what's coming
um and then I'm going to talk a bit
about recourse um we've had that term um
previously so um this just to remind you
very close I mean the number the size of
the changes introduced to the solution
due to an update or a batch of updates
so in fact the size of difference
between
um the previous solution and the next
solution
so um in this talk
um I would like to um we'll talk about
two examples of large areas I'm
interested in so the first area is
dynamic algorithms for data centers and
here I picked the problem that deals
with this joint matchings and KH
coloring
um the second area I'm interested in one
a secondary I'm interested in and our
Dynamic algorithms for basic problems so
here I picked them a very basic problem
reachability
and then at the end I want to come back
to the title of this talk actually so I
want to say a bit about what it means to
engineer Dynamic graphics
all right so
um
let's start with the first topic so um
within a data center we have um usually
a lot of applications running run
applications such as distributed machine
learning or data mining or also um if
you want to access remote resources like
GPU or memory that's not local to the
machine that our applications are
currently running on then this requires
large data transfers and actually
um it has been shown that
these
communication between different machines
within a data center is actually a
bottleneck to um
efficient computations
um
yeah
so um
initially we have a situation that
within a data center we have um uh yeah
set of
top of Rex which is um that are
typically connected by a fixed apology
so it's not really important for this
talk what this topology is it could be
some tree-like structure for example but
um yeah as I said it's not really
important you can assume that they are
all connected um to each other they can
all communicate with each other but not
necessarily um equally fast
so um what one could do or what then can
or can do is introduce
um or use additional technology like for
example Optical switches an optical
switch is able to establish additional
direct connections between such top of
rack switches they have very high
bandwidth and they are reconfigurable
within microseconds so they can connect
um pairs of of such type of rack
switches
um at one point of time and then you
reconfigure them and then they compare
different set of um
Pairs and of course we can have just one
applicable switch but multiple
so the key question here is how do we
configure those opticals which is
optimally to offload a maximum amount of
communication
um
demand to those Optical switches
so
um
well in order to to attack this problem
we can look at the communication demand
graph so on the right here um we have a
graph having a Vertex for each type of
rack switch
um and then we have an edge between two
two vertices with a certain weight and
the weight corresponds to the
communication demand
so when we have an optical switch that
connects pairs of vertices or vertex
corresponds to top of X with top of Rec
switch so um
if you have such an optical switch then
in fact this corresponds to a matching
in our communication demand graph and if
you want to offer the maximum amount of
um communication demand to those Optical
switches then
um we are looking for
um a heavy matching a matching of large
weight
and um when we have a second opticals
virtual then we just have a second
um matching in the graph
so in fact we can say that each match
sorry each Optical switch
um corresponds to a matching on the
graph or we could also say
um we are trying to color the edges of
our communication demand graph
um
using as many colors as we have Optical
switches
so um
you can model this problem either as
finding a set of key disjoint matchings
of Maximum total weight or we could say
we're looking for an edge coloring using
K colors
so we try to assign each Edge either one
of K colors or bottom meaning that this
Edge remains uncolored such that
um
well each coloring is a matching and in
total
um all colored edges together have a
maximum weight
we also assume in this setting here that
we have like a centralized controller
that is able to observe the
communication demand between
um our top of Rex which is and can
reconfigure the optical switches
so um we end up with um well the
weighted KH coloring problem or we could
also call it a weighted K disjoint
matchings problem given a graph
eventually it's w find a KH coloring
that maximizes
um the total weight of the colored edges
okay
um well of course this is not a static
problem
um
because the communication demand and
therefore the edge rates change over
time it depends on the application that
we're running
um or that is running on on those
servers in the data center
um it determines
um well who communicates with whom so
there may be changes for example we
might have um this solution here this
configuration and then um
for one pair of of nodes um the weight
decreases so we have less communication
but it increases for another pair
um of nodes so there are two things that
we can do we could either just recompute
from scratch
um and just take the modified graph
compute a new coloring after a certain
number of weight changes
um or we could try to update our current
coloring
of course
um if we update our current coloring
um we hope that we only need to consider
the part of the graph where the changes
actually occur
so this um should lead to a speed up in
computation
and second
um we can
avoid unnecessary configuration changes
so each configuration change means that
they have to Recon figure um the these
Optical switches maybe um previously in
the connection was established by the
first Optical switch and now I just move
it to the second Optical switch this may
be completely unnecessary so I'm also
trying to
um
have as few recolorings as possible it
should lead to a speed up in
configuration
so
um what is known about this problem
um
first um
okay there's a sort of obvious
connection to weighted matching which is
a special case word we just have one
color or we're looking for one matching
and we all know that this is some
efficiently solvable and also very well
studied also in the dynamic setting
on the other side we have the edge
coloring problem which is one of the
classic MP heart problems and here one
could say okay if I set K the number of
colors to the maximum degree and all
Edge rates um to one then I get exactly
the classic problem
so we're somewhere in between these two
problems
um but it turns out that um the radio
cage coloring problem is MP heart and
also apx hard already for K greater
equal to
um so when you want to solve this
problem in practice it makes sense look
at approximation algorithms or
heuristics
and also um this problem has been
studied
um
also experimentally before in fact um we
did this uh two years ago and looked at
this problem
um just from a static setting
um where we don't have any changes in
the edge rates
okay so
um here we tried to come up with um
intelligent and fast and fully Dynamic
algorithms um for this um cage coloring
problem and one key operation
um or two key operations actually are
swap art and swap in so if I have an
edge e that is assigned some color like
the red color in this example
by swap art E I mean that I'm looking at
the edges um
incident to the he on both end modes and
I'm trying to find two edges that I can
color with this red color and that have
to get a larger weight than e hat this
would be successful for that operation
the context for the Apple from the
application
how large are these graphs and if you're
supporting this big computation
how much time is spent doing the updates
to this graph compared to the actual
computation the actual problem that the
that these computers are trying to solve
um so the um so we did experiments on on
real world traces so
um
data from from data centers
um and there we had like the
communication demand crafts had
thousands of nodes but not much larger
um we also run experiments on large
instances but they were generated
because we couldn't get suggestions
and get such instances like we could get
such real world instances so we
generated larger ones and also evaluated
algorithms on this but yeah there were
World instances had like
some of them were pretty dense
oh I think it was a second question
the other question was if this is being
done in the application in support of
some larger computations yes
how much time is spent even in the
slowest version of the even in a static
if you used if you didn't use Dynamic
algorithms what percentage of the time
is spent doing this as opposed to the
actual computation you're trying to
support
I'm trying to see does does the speed of
this Dynamic algorithm matter in the
broader context
um yeah that would be interesting to you
to evaluate so far we haven't uh we
haven't tried it so we here we only
concentrated on Computing the
configurations and we assume that this
is done on some dedicated Hardware
um
and we can't do it within
microseconds or a few milliseconds I'm
like update these configurations but so
far we haven't evaluated
um
what it actually means for the speed up
of
applications that are running or how it
can improve the throughput um in in the
network actually so this would be
hugeable of course
we are looking into it
um
right
so um yeah coming back to those two
primitive operations for about um
I already explained and swap in as sort
of the the opposite so for swapping I'm
giving an edge that is currently
uncalled I'm giving
um I'm looking at a specific color like
the red one here and um I'm trying to
color e with this color
um with the red color here and
uncoloring um the two adjacent edges but
only if this leads to an increase
in the total weight of the colored edges
so only if e has larger weight than it's
two adjacent edges
um
um based on this
um we designed a randomized dynamic
greedia algorithm that takes two
parameters Alpha and beta which I will
come to
um in a minute so what it does is uh in
fact whenever we have a weight update on
an he so the way it changes by some
Delta
um if Delta is positive so the weight of
the edge increases
um and the edge is currently uncolored
if it's colored already we don't have
there's nothing to do for us so but if
it's currently uncolored we
um are interested in Coloring it now so
we first check whether there is a free
color
um C Prime on both
um and vertices and if this is the case
we just color The Edge um with this
color and you're done
otherwise um we're looking at up to Beta
colors that are drawn randomly from our
set of K colors and we are looking at um
these uh at the Swap in operation for
all these colors and um
yeah trying to find the best one here
if um this swap in operation is
successful this means that um there are
two adjacent edges that are now
uncolored so we um just try to color
those edges again so we recurse
um here but um here the first parameter
comes into play we only do this for
Alpha minus one times so Alpha limits
number of recursive calls here
the second scenario where we have to
take action is that the weight of DHE
decreases so Delta is negative and
um because the edge is colored
then um we um again look at up to be the
incident edges on each end vertex and um
now we look at the swab out operation so
we try to uncolor e and see whether we
can find two Json edges but together
have larger weight and can be colored
with um the color that e had previously
if this is successful then this means
that e is now on color so we um try once
to color it again but we don't um do any
recursive steps here
so this is our Dynamic greedy algorithm
the first one
um we also um designed another Dynamic
um algorithm that is based on
aesthetic algorithm called kec okay you
see it just means coloring
um so this um KCA group most interesting
for us because it turned out to be the
um the past or the yeah the best static
algorithm
um for this problem
in an earlier study so kec just to give
you some context is an adaptation of the
Delta plus one Edge coloring algorithm
by Miser and Greece if you are familiar
with this algorithm
um but um yeah it is modified
um because
um
we have a special sedation here with
Edge weights and a limited number of
colors and so on
so um for reasons of time I cannot go
too much into detail here
um but this is another Dynamic algorithm
we designed
and then
um we also designed post-processing
um
post-processing routine
um that maintains the following
invariant that for each uncolored Edge e
and each color
um
see this color C is not free on both and
no nodes and swap in
um for this Edge and this color yields
no improvement so in fact this means
that um
for each on color that um there is no um
I cannot perform a swap in operation
um for any color basically
and if you maintain this invariant
um then we know that our solution is
someone half approximation
so um well this is an invariant that can
rather easily be established you can
either apply it as a post-processing um
and if you do so I will append the
suffix of minus P to the algorithm name
or we can just call it um Standalone and
then we call this algorithm batch two
it's fetch to approx
um then we looked at a filtering
approach where the idea was that if the
weight of an edge only change a little
um then this probably doesn't have a
large effect on on our solution
so um if we filter out those updates
ignore those updates that only change
their trades um
um yeah by a little amount
um then this should lead to a speed up
of our algorithm and maybe also improve
the recourse
um so we did this year in fact we
compare the new Edge weight
um to the old Edge weight and if it was
in the range or from 1 over T and T or t
is a parameter
um then we ignored this um Edge weight
change and this can be applied as a
pre-processing to any algorithm uh in
fact so just filter out the updates
um by the way it doesn't change
sufficiently
um in this and algorithms if you use
this for an algorithm then we use a
suffix minus F I want to do something
um
it also
um then designed some hybrid algorithms
so the idea was that um
in some cases if you have like only a
few changes to the graph the dynamic
algorithm may be faster because it only
needs to um to consider the updates
themselves but if we have a lot of
updates
um if for example the entire graph
changes
um
by by a batch of updates on a static
algorithm may be faster
so for our hybrid hybrid algorithms we
try to file in a balance between these
two and the hybrid algorithms use the
dynamic algorithm if the size of the
previous batch was smaller than the
number of nodes in the graph and
otherwise it uses a static algorithm so
there's some
um of course a heuristic I'm going to
switch to the dynamic algorithm when you
use a static algorithm
um but we found that this um was sort of
A good rule
so um we have two Dynamic algorithms the
ingredients see that already mentioned
and for the static aggravity only use
the kuc which as I mentioned before show
the best time for Quality trade-off uh
in Prior work so I'm combining these
gave us a hybrid greedy and a hybrid KCA
group
um we also designed several batch
Dynamic algorithms which I did not
include here um for for reasons of time
um and um yeah also because in the
empirical evaluation which I will talk
about next
um they did not play uh
so for our empirical evaluation
um as I mentioned before we did those on
real world instances so we had 30
instances
um that um were obtained from Facebook
data center traces
um a collection called P Fabric and then
um also some traces from high
performance computing
so in fact we had communication and data
here like um packets
um with a source destination a packet
size and a timestamp so the timestamp of
each packet told us um the patch so um
all packets that were at the same time
stamp um correspond to updates that um
be grouped um within a batch and the
packet and sizes um told us the um the
edge rate
so we had various batch sizes um they
could be rather large up to 66.4 K and
also um we had instances where we had up
to 5000 batches um
so um what did we find
um what you can see here are results for
k equal to eight so we have eight
Optical switches here we did experiments
um for K between two and uh
6 64 I think 32 or 64.
um
and um yeah so the result shown here of
okay equal to two
um you can see um the box plots which um
tell us the time per update for each
batch
um and the diamond
um gives the geometric mean
what's the update times
um and on on the right side
um you can see um the geometric mean
weight which is shown as a star in the
plot
so
um for the Stars we want them to be as
far to the top as possible and for um
the boxes and the Diamonds you want them
to be as little as possible
so um on the very left um this is the
static algorithm kec which we used um
um yeah for comparison
and as a baseline sort of so you can see
that it has um it produces very good
Solutions the star is um
but the running time can be rather large
then next um are the two hybrid
algorithms
um
and you can see that they have a sort of
similar quality as a static wand
um but they are faster
um and often even much faster than the
static one
then uh for among the batch Dynamic
algorithms um only the batch 2 API
access included here which guarantees
this two approximation this one has
approximation this was actually the only
by Dynamic I would know it was
competitive I was especially good on the
P fabric instances
foreign
s which are shown next on the plot here
um there are two versions were passed um
or in fact among the dynamic greedy one
they wanted to use the post-processing
the filtering and
um pictures uh so if this better
parameter was set to one so we just
picked one colon
um randomly for our swap swap in
operation this one showed the best
performance
um the dynamic kec version also with
post-processing and filtering
um similar but slightly slower so these
are um these two here
this processing internally was efficient
efficient and effect well efficient it
cost some time but it was effective for
algorithms except for the kec and the
hybrid case so apparently these
algorithms did not need the extra post
processing
filtering turned out to be
um
effective in reducing the running time
but also reduce the solution quality so
it turned out to be only useful if
combined with post processing then we
could get the improved solution quality
from the post processing and the reduced
running time from the filtering
and when looking at the recourse um was
as sort of expected the dynamic
algorithms had this lowest recourse
hybrid um were a bit worse and the
static algorithm had um the largest
recourse how important were speakers for
the application
um
well it means um basically yeah it
measures how how many reconfigurations I
have to I have to make and to to this
Optical switch
um I was told that it is not the most
important Criterium so speed would be
running time would be more important
here
um and solution quality of course
um
then and we found that unfortunately
sort of um our real world traces only
had a temporal resolution of one second
whereas our Optical switches can be
reconfigured within microseconds and you
can see I don't know if you can read
this but also the update time is um yeah
a microsecond or less
so um we also um wanted to simulate
hierarchy correlation frequencies and we
just split up the batches into sub
batches with limited Edge rates and
generated another 26 instances from that
and just want to go over this um quickly
so this picture in the over a picture
was similar there are some differences
filtering for example had no effect here
due to weight limits
um the hybrid algorithms were similar to
the static one to static algorithm in
all respects the fastest um
algorithm here in the set were the
dynamic really without filtering and the
batch batch 2 apx algorithm especially
if cables
for recourse we have a similar
um similar results as before
and post-processing again was very
effective but could I had a an effect on
recourse
um and as I said before we also um did
some experiments on synthetic instances
because those real instances were rather
small in comparison so we generated
um graphs um using an armored generator
were drawn from exponential distribution
and this allowed us to create larger
instances and also control the fraction
five of updated edges per batch
so you can see um the plot for k equal
to 2 8 and 32 the speed up
of different algorithms over the static
kec algorithms so um this is would be
the one line here shows the running time
of the kec algorithm and um the further
up the larger the speed up over this
algorithm
what we found is that Dynamic and Patch
Dynamic algorithms are faster than the
static algorithm if Phi was a small if
it was at most 0.1
um the speed up decreases as K increase
okay so if you go to larger k then the
speed up decreases you can see this here
an all S5 increase
increases on the speed up of the
algorithm decreases in comparison to KAC
um generally the hybrid algorithms were
faster than the static ones for small
Phi and equally fast for larger so this
is good it means atom hybrid is um some
Superior to kec with respect to running
time here the solution quality was
closer to the static one for larger K
but for small K it could be even less
than 90 percent
um so for the small for small K the
hybrid may be not the ideal um
choice
interesting here was also that the space
batch 2 apx algorithm always produced
solution quality within three percent of
the static AC algorithm which is very
good
so in summary what which algorithms
should one choose those are the
interesting candidates in some way
so
um if we have small batch size and okay
a small our recommendation would be to
go for dispatch to apx algorithm if K is
a bit larger then one should go for the
one of the two Dynamic algorithms
if you have large batches then the two
hybrid algorithms are good choices in
our opinion
if you don't know anything about your
instance we also recommend to go for
hybrid algorithms
um if you say that quality is the most
important issue you do not care so much
about running time or a recourse go for
the static algorithm and you'll get the
best solution quality and the free
course is the most important thing to
you don't care so much about solution
quality for example
or running time go further than any
course
and yeah this source code is also
available uh publicly on GitHub so if
you're interested you can of
transitional songs
okay
[Music]
um
any questions
you probably have to repeat it
[Music]
so I've heard the word adversary a whole
bunch and is there an opposite of an
adversary like if you had an oracle
scheduler that knew every past and
future change that was going to make
like how much better could it do in
terms of quality like twice as good
eight times it's like well that's
another good question
um for runtime
I'm just wondering how far you are away
from the perfect
um
I'm perfect with respect to running time
no runtime or quality or whatever metric
you happen to pick like you know are you
one percent away or are you five times
as bad or like what would you know okay
um so it um it really um it depends a
lot on Kenny so the larger K the better
yeah algorithms become
um for a static um
um well we'll look at this problem in
the static setting we also um
actually computed the optimal solution
and we found that for example this kec
which we use it as a baseline Here Comes
um really close to to the optimal
Solution on
but significantly faster of course I
don't remember
um how much glass how close actually I
mean we have
um a two approximation guarantee here so
we're at least within 50 with the
experimentally I think we were much
closer okay
closer than your approximation yeah
that's cool okay
okay
um
so um yeah the other problem I wanted to
talk about is a very basic one
reachability
um so I think you all know what's around
for each abilities in fact we can have
can look at the settings using the
source reachability where um we are we
keep the source vertex fixed or only
you're interested in
um
whether some vertex T can be reached
from The Source vertex s so our query
consists only of one vertex t or for all
pairs reachability also called
transitive closure
um we give both vertices actually s and
t and we ask but there's a directed path
for this
so when we started to work on this
problem
um there were two experimental studies
um so far they were very large
um one by three Junior dial and the
other by commuters and sarilagus and
they compared many fully Dynamic
algorithms also beautifully Dynamic
algorithms to study graph traversal and
what they found was that the fastest
algorithms on most instances were those
static raft traversal algorithms like
BFS DFS
um and the strongest competitors of
those algorithms were actually fully
Dynamic extensions of two partially
Dynamic algorithms that maintain
strongly connected components
due to Italiano originally and the other
rodity and Swig and they were made fully
Dynamic by the authors of the study
um but they were only they could only be
the static raft of muscle algorithms if
either there were the graphs are very
dense
um or there were very uh few queries
and also in this um studies um the
instances were mostly random and very
few random uh real gold
so um when we started to look uh into
readability we first looked at a single
Source Rich ability
um and um then at some point we already
had um single social durability
algorithms which um performed very well
and we were thinking of um using them to
solve the old pass readability problem
as well so I'm going to talk about all
pass readability
um here
um and our idea was the following
suppose that we have a Vertex V and for
this vertex we know the set of vertices
that
um
we can reach
I will call the set R plus so sort of
outreachability and the set of vertices
that can reach V so sort of in a set of
unreachable yeah enrichability
um so for me I know these two sets of
vertices now if I have a query whether s
can vertex s can read a Vertex T
um what I could try to or how could how
I could try to answer those queries
um if I know that s can reach V because
s in is in this in reachability set of v
and T is in this outreachability set of
me
um then of course I can immediately um
say that s can reach t
just using this information on 4B
um also if for example s can be reached
from V but T cannot
I can immediately say that then ask can
also not HT
and symmetrically if I know that t can
reach V but s cannot
then I also know that s cannot reach t
so from this video observation the first
one gives us a positive answer which
ability s can reach T and the other two
give us a negative answer
and um
record we support effort uh supportive
vertex so for
um because it supports Us in answering
reachability queries
and then we build um a couple of
algorithms around this um idea uh so in
general
um the idea is that we store a list of
supportive vertices
and for each supportive vertex we
maintain the set of out and in reachable
unreachable vertices using single source
and single synchritability algorithms
Dynamic algorithms here
we just forward these updates to this
SSR algorithms and whenever a query
comes we just try the our support
vertices in some order and see whether
we can answer the query by one of those
observations and if this is not possible
we fall back to static graph traversal
so
um
what's not specified yet is first how do
we pick our support if vertices then to
be something in addition to just
forwarding updates to those SSR
algorithms and how
how do we well pick the order in which
we query um the vertices
um
but to support
um us for underage ability queries
um
I came up with three algorithms um
SE
um SV and SVA so SV is a simple simplest
one
um it just picks K vertices a supportive
vertices during initialization so it
first sees the graph
um and then um it yeah
sticks with those SVA does the same for
initialization
um
so PK vertices are supportive vertices
and they pick uniformly at random from
set of four vertices
as we see
um uses um strongly connected components
um to pick could support the vertices so
it first compute the strongly connected
components of the graph and then we have
some threshold parameter set
um if um Australia connected component
is a
exceeds the threshold then we pick a
supportive vertex for this component as
representative and we maintain a map
um that tells us for each vertex the
corresponding representative if it
exists
um but an update comes in addition to
forwarding the updates to the SSR
algorithms and for SVA and SVC we
re-initialize our data structures every
C updates so see is another parameter
here
um and this is on also the only
difference between SV and SVA
so SV does never reinitialize it sticks
with uh it's a supported
when a query comes then SV and SVA I'll
just try to support the vertices
um in the order they were picked so no
specific order and um if they could not
answer the
um the query using those vertices they
fall back to static retroversal
as we see
um can look up and use the
representatives
um it may
find that the representatives are no
longer valid because there have been
changes to the graph and we um haven't
recomputed our strongly connected
components
um in this case invalid entries are just
removed from the map and then it falls
back to the mode of SV and SVA so it
does not try to to fix the strongly
components in any way this only would
happen
um every C updates
um
during this reinitialization
and some experiments um for these
algorithms um
so if we look at the update times then
you can see the the purple algorithms
are the SV algorithms using one two and
three supportive vertices and you can
see quite well that um each additional
supportive vertex increases the update
time
um the two green lines correspond to the
SBC algorithmet has to strongly
connected components and you can see
that for example
um
this um
the okay in fact they both use only one
um maintain only one strongly connected
component um most of the time so for for
medium to large densities
um
and this re-initialization which um
happens here and also for the blue once
the SVA algorithms this is uh quite
costly so it increases the updates time
um quite a lot
if you look at the query time
um here we have also the static
algorithms included
um so those are the typical traditional
DFS BFS algorithms there up here then we
Implement a bi-directional BFS which was
um way faster but still a lot slower
than our Dynamic algorithms so um you
can see here that the fastest algorithms
to answer the queries were the SVC
algorithms
um then this SV algorithms using um
well two or three supported vertices and
here's the one that uses one supportive
vertex the line comes down here and then
also this is uh yeah almost no time to
answer queries for the tensor graphs
oh equally many insertions deletions and
queries
um then this is the result
so
um unless the graphs are very sparse
um whether by direction of BFS is
competitive and the dynamic algorithms
are much faster the fastest ones are in
fact um for the sparser graphs the SVC
um algorithm that never
um
re-initialize it re-initializes here and
the SBA agree with pictures one
supportive vertex and this picture also
does not change if you go to larger
graphs with uh pieces
um
in the interest of time I will skip over
this
um we also did experiments on stochastic
chronic instances equally many
insertions deletions and queries
um the fastest were again as sv1 sv2 and
the SVC algorithm which re-initializes
the fewest
the static algorithms were um far from
competitive
um and we have the same picture if we
look at real world instances
um this will hackerlink networks again
twice as many updates as queries again
the fastest
V1 lsp2 Illustrated algorithms were not
competitive in any way
so
which algorithm is the best we think
those three are the interesting
algorithms
um
where sv2 in comparison to sv1 has a
more stable query time but double update
time and as we see also has a more
stable query time it is fast on sparse
instances so if your spouse instances
maybe the better choice but yeah the
time is considerably increased and would
be interesting to see what happens if we
reinitialize even less often
um so this is something we are currently
working on
and um yeah slower personal orders of
magnitude the static algorithms
which I think is nice because it shows
the dynamic algorithms actually
um work in practice
[Music]
um
okay I will also skip this um because I
only have two minutes left so I wanted
to talk a bit about engineer Dynamic
graph algorithms in the remaining time
um so generally
um what does it mean to to
experimentally evaluate Dynamic
algorithms some
first question is what do we want what
do we need to measure usually or okay we
want to to
um to measure solution quality running
time is usually very important sometimes
also recourse memory communication IO
whatever
um so I want to focus a bit on running
time um here because for dynamic
algorithms the next question immediately
is what exactly do I want to measure
when I talk about running time am I
interested initialization time
usually not so much because if I have
long update sequences initialization
time
it's it's not so important I'm more
interested in how far can I process the
updates
um so um okay I may be interested in um
the update time or the time to process
an entire batch of updates or the query
time but um then
the question is am I interested in the
time for each update each batch of
updates each query or I might just fine
with getting a total time like the total
time for the entire update sequence for
example maybe even intermixed with
queries
um and if I'm interested in single
update or query times well this often
gives interesting insights you can for
example see
um by the insertions or deletions are
faster or I'm also
um
how how much this fluctuates but this is
also a challenge in many cases because
the time for a single update or query
can be very very small
so um the experiments here become highly
sensitive to all kinds of interferences
from the system our experiments are
running on
so um what one can do about this is
first repeat experiments multiple times
I mean this is a gold standard anyway in
algorithm engineering
um but it's even um more important
um if you are trying to measure such
small running times and second prepare
the system for benchmarks prepare it
well so reduce other processes try to
run uh well
stop all other processes they're not not
um not needed to have a dedicated
machine where to run the process leave
the experiments on disable frequency
scaling you don't want your CPU to go to
power save mode in between
or something like that also be aware of
pneumo architecture so um how expensive
is it to access some memory um this may
not be the same cost
um
in each case
and
um one more thing
um when measuring such small times
you may
consider whether to include or exclude
the update time that your underlying
graph that is structure actually needs
to for example insert an edge into the
graph or remove an edge from the graph
because if you have very very small
update times you may in in the end just
measure the the update time of the graph
data structure rather than the update
time of year algorithm so
it depends on
how complicated your algorithms is or
how efficient the graph that the
structure is but yeah and usually you
want to say something about the
algorithm and not necessarily about the
graph data structure
um right what about Dynamic graph
instances
um So currently there are
a couple of dynamic instances out there
but they are hard to get so sometimes
one gets edges with timestamps but then
they are insertions only and there's
some specialized craft generators also
but what people do usually is doing some
undoing approach sliding window remove
an ad or morphing a snapshot approach I
think we've heard this before so we're
not going to detail here what I haven't
heard so far is um I think it's an open
problem if the algorithm does not
maintain a solution it may be really
want what what queries are actually use
to to evaluate my algorithms
random queries or are there some sort of
real world queries and
and this is last slide so what else can
influence experiments memory usage and
cash effects we've heard this
characteristics of the update sequence
build up or dismantle structures like
paths this can have a huge influence
um
in my experience Edge lifetimes how long
until an inserted Edge is removed again
so here you can different see different
um examples of a random graph one random
Dynamic graph one that was created from
different snapshots and the last one is
a real world Dynamic graphic I think
that's it sorry for going a bit over
time
[Applause]
so we have time for let's say one quick
question
hi a great presentation
um I just have a quick question about
the data sets you used for your
reachability
um experiments so for your random graphs
how did you generate the random graphs
of different densities
uh foreign graphs
um if I'm not incorrect about this they
have good expansion properties expand
their properties right
um so the other question is for
um is it interesting to test
um your
um algorithm all these algorithms on
high diameter graphs
um are any of the real world graphs that
it has it on and do they have high
diameter
um I'm I haven't looked into it
I'm not sure
yeah
I would have to look it up okay thank
you thank you
all right then let's thank Catherine and
we asked question offline thanks
[Applause]